- [Announcer] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is William Cronon
who is the Frederick
Jackson Turner professor
of history, geography and
environmental studies,
and the Vilas research professor
at the University of Wisconsin at Madison.
Professor Cronon, welcome to Berkeley.
- [William] Thanks for having me.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in New Haven, Connecticut.
I'm an academic brat,
so I've lived in university
towns all my life.
I spent the first six years
of my life in New Haven,
a couple of years in Lincoln, Nebraska,
and then from third grade on
through the end of my undergraduate years
in Madison, Wisconsin.
- Looking back how did your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- Pretty deeply I would say.
My father was an American
historian as I am.
I ended up following in his footsteps
much more closely than I
ever imagined that I would.
From him I learned the habit of
looking at pretty much
everything historically
asking how did things get to be this way?
He was a wonderful storyteller,
and always had historical
stories to tell about
wherever it was that we might be.
My mother was really interested in
natural history and science,
and those ended up being kind of
the converging interests of my life.
I'm kind of endlessly
fascinated by nature,
but I tend to approach
nature historically.
For me almost everything
has a story in it,
and finding those stories
is what I really devoted my life to doing.
- I have the sense from reading about you,
and reading your writings that
being in Wisconsin
really shaped you in a
very distinctive way.
- Yeah, I would say that's true,
and many complicated ways that ranged from
Wisconsin it's a Midwestern
kind of humble landscape.
It doesn't have the sublime
drama of California.
It's rolling hills, lot of
flatlands, lot of wetlands.
It's not a dramatic place,
and yet it's also a place
where there's a lot of nature,
and there's also a lot of
people living near nature.
Often nature's that other people
might not even notice were nature,
so a lot of farming, a lot of woodlands.
It's a culture in which people
are outdoors all the time,
and that was the world I grew up in.
My hobby as a boy was
actually cave exploring.
I had friends with whom
I went all over the state of Wisconsin
trying to find caves, and exploring caves.
I came to read the Wisconsin landscape
for what was underneath it
looking at the landscape
trying to figure out where caves might be,
and that notion that there's
a hidden invisible world,
a world that most people
don't know how to see,
and if you can only learn to look for it
you see things that other people don't.
Oddly, cave exploring was one of my ways
of learning how to do that.
- I think I read somewhere
that in high school was it
that you did a project on
vegetation where you were
making note of all the
different vegetation around you?
- Yeah, one of the things that
a lot of people were doing
in the mid 20th century,
and I would have been
late to this process,
but Wisconsin was one of the
places where it was pioneered
was they used the original
land survey records
when the federal surveyors
first came across the landscape,
and put the grid down
that turned landscape
into real estate in many
parts of the United States,
and they would cite the trees
as they laid down that grid.
It turns out you can use those trees
the trees that marked
the corners of the grid
as a kind of ecological sample
of what the vegetation in
that landscape looked like
150 years ago now.
A high school research project that I did
in my junior and senior
years of high school
was to take a county in Wisconsin,
look at all the survey marks,
and build a map of what
the vegetation had been
in that county in the 1840s, 1830s.
- I know that you are
very focused on the link
between history and nature,
but it also sounds like the
history of nature itself,
in other words, it's evolution over time.
- Oh, yeah, very much so.
In fact, I entered college
thinking partly based on
the project you just asked about
that I would be a
quantitative plant ecologist,
and for a while I thought
I would be a geologist.
In fact, geology has
been a passion of mine,
actually, all the way back to those caves,
and it continues to be
kind of a passion of mine.
In a funny kind of way
geology, ecology, human history
they're all history,
they're all the story of
landscape change over time.
I often think of landscape
as one of my favorite words
is the word for medieval
manuscripts a palimpsest
in which these very
valuable pieces of vellum
that the monks would
write on were so valuable
that they couldn't bear to throw them out,
and when they were done
with the manuscript
they scraped off the letters,
and wrote something new on that vellum.
You can now read the hidden
script on those documents
if you know how to do so,
and the idea that landscape is like that
that's it's layer upon layer
of texts that we can read
if we know the language
if we have the skills.
The languages come from
many different disciplines,
geology, ecology, chemistry,
physics, astronomy,
English literature, you name it.
I'm interested in, yes,
the history of nature,
and I'm interested in the history
of the way we think about
nature our ideas of nature.
- You started in photography very early
so the visual is very important for you.
- The visual has been very
important to me all along.
My dad had photography as a hobby,
another thing that he gave me,
and he actually had an old
Kodak 35 millimeter Rangefinder camera
that I think had been his camera
in the late 1940s, early 1950s.
One of my proudest possessions as a boy
was when he had moved onto an SLR,
a much more advanced modern camera,
and he gave me this old Rangefinder.
I'd say for about, oh,
five, six, seven years
that camera was one of the ways
that I would go into the landscape,
and see the landscape through
the frame of the camera's eye.
So that, too, was a skill, right?
Learning how to see through a lens,
and thinking through
what the lens requires
both technically in terms of exposure,
but also aesthetically
in terms of composition,
and the history of how
cameras have that form,
and the history of why
we frame the way we do.
All those, too, have stories
that I'm interested in exploring.
- Also important for you has been
the University of Wisconsin
both in the sense that
that's where you did your
undergraduate training,
and it's where you came back from Yale
after getting your education,
your advanced education at
Yale and teaching at Yale.
Talk about Wisconsin
you as an undergraduate,
and any particular professor
who really influenced you.
- Yeah, well, I was very, very much formed
by the University of Wisconsin,
and remember I was the
child of a professor there,
so when I say I'm an academic brat
there's a way in which I was
in the University of Wisconsin
from third grade forward
in a funny kind of way,
so I grew up my high school
was with a lot of academic kids
we were exposed to the
university all along.
I would say it's what you've
heard me describe about
the interest of people in a landscape
has actually been an intellectual passion
of that institution really
going back to the 19th century
with initial awareness that Wisconsin
is a glaciated landscape,
and the reading of
glaciation in that landscape
is a way of understanding, again,
the hidden scripts of Wisconsin.
Frederick Jackson Turner
one of the best-known
of the faculty members on that
campus in the 19th century
with his idea of the frontier
that, too, had a big influence on me.
As an undergrad the teachers
who most affected me
by far the most important was
a man named Richard Ringler
who I almost by accident took a course
in my freshman year
called the Anglo-Saxons,
which was a literature course,
but really a cultural history course on
Dark Age Britain from the 5th century AD
to about the 12th century AD,
and he taught that course with
pictures and with objects,
and with a kind of
kaleidoscopic understanding
of what the landscape of Great Britain
had been like during that period,
the ideas, the cultures, all of that.
One other teacher in my
senior year taught a course
on the history of the American
West and the frontier,
and that's what sort of turned me away
from the Middle Ages and
toward the American West,
and I eventually went
to Yale to learn about,
and then teach the Trans-Mississippi West,
but when I got the chance
to come back to Madison
15 years later I chose to do that.
- One of the interests that I
like to pursue in my program
is kind of how intellectual
communities emerge,
and what are their foundation.
Is it the landscape that
you've just described,
and what Wisconsin's relation to nature
that is formative here?
Has it been the genius of
the leaders of the university
so that you get an intellectual community
that really reflects
this natural environment?
- Yeah, it's a really great question,
and we could spend the next hour
just trying to answer that question,
which I know you don't want to do,
so a couple of quick answers.
I've been puzzling about this
question really all my life.
I'm quite intrigued why
the University of Wisconsin
has this kind of peculiar culture.
Many other universities
that are great institutions
don't have the kind of
embeddedness in place
that that place has had
and it's partly leaders.
It's partly people like
Frederick Jackson Turner,
or Aldo Leopold, folks
like that that people know,
or for that matter John Muir
who we associate with California,
but who grew up in Wisconsin,
and was very much shaped by Wisconsin,
but oddly an institutional
explanation I would say is that
UW-Madison is actually one
of the very few universities
in the country that is both
the liberal arts university,
and the land-grant engineering
and agricultural school.
Many, many Midwestern states
have a University of
Iowa and an Iowa State,
or a University of Kansas
and a Kansas State,
but in Wisconsin the legislature,
actually, over the opposition
of the Madison faculty
insisted that the
land-grant the ag school,
the engineering school
be on the same campus
as the liberal arts school.
Oddly, I think it's
actually been that dialogue
between the liberal arts tradition
the kind of broad understanding
of the human experience
which is the great I think contribution
of the liberal art perspective
to higher education
with the much more
practical applied knowledge
of the ag schools, the engineering schools
those kinds of professional schools
that really has created a
really interesting dialogue
at UW-Madison much of it over agriculture.
- I also get a sense in
reading up about you,
and the ideas that have motivated you
that this University of Wisconsin setting,
and Madison and Wisconsin
imbue one with a sense of
community and community service,
and the public good and so on.
- Very much so and that's
a tradition that goes back
really to the governorship
of Bob La Follette
the great progressive Republican governor
at the beginning of the 20th century
whose roommate in college
had actually been a man named
Charles Richard Van Hise
who was the first PhD from
the University of Wisconsin.
Van Hise would actually
write the first textbook
on natural resource conservation
in the United States.
They were very close friends,
and when La Follette became governor
he and his old roommate hatched the idea
which they called The Wisconsin Idea
that the university should exist
in the service of the people of the state,
and the motto of that
was that the boundaries
of the university are the
boundaries of the state.
We now say the boundaries of the state,
the boundaries of the nation,
the boundaries of the world,
but this idea that the
university exists to serve
that is it's not in an ivory
tower separate from the world,
but it is in the world
and being in the world
intellectual work needs to be in dialogue
with what's out there in the world,
so Wisconsin led the way.
It invented the idea of social security.
There are actually a whole
series of public policy reforms
in the early 20th century
that came out of this Wisconsin idea,
and then by the time of the new deal
were being mapped onto
the nation as a whole.
- You then after doing
your BA work in Wisconsin
you took a break from
Wisconsin so to speak,
and were Rhodes Scholar at Oxford,
and then graduate student at Yale,
and then you taught at Yale.
What did you get that
was different or additive
in these two educational experiences?
- Well, that, too, would
be a complicated question.
Oxford was revelatory to
me in all sorts of ways.
Living in England living
in the British Isles
was revelatory because this
habit of reading landscape
that I had already acquired from Madison
in England the time depth and
the multitude of cultural,
and environmental layers
that take you back
from the present day to
the Industrial Revolution
to before the Industrial
Revolution to the enclosures
to the Norman French to the Anglo-Saxons
to the Celts to the Romans
those layers are all
legible in that landscape.
The English the Brits in general
have had a fascination for that place
I would say that surpasses most
places in the United States.
It was just
a feast for somebody
with my kind of curiosity
to be in that kind of place
with those kinds of guides,
and I wrote a dissertation
there on energy consumption
because I was working in the late 1970s
at the time of the energy crisis,
but I knew I wanted to come back,
and work on the history
of the American West,
and at that time, interestingly,
Yale was one of the leading
places in the United States
to study the Trans-Mississippi
West because of a wonderful
scholar and teacher
there named Howard Lamar,
and I came to work with him.
He became the dean of Yale College,
and I essentially was
hired to be his replacement
while he was being dean.
What I think I got from
both Oxford and Yale
that I hadn't gotten from
Wisconsin was the idea of
it's hard to describe
institutions that were deeply committed to
undergraduates learning
in a liberal arts college
kind of community setting,
so the idea that undergrads
were in small communities
which is not Wisconsin strength,
and for that matter Berkeley strength.
It's not smallness it's largeness,
and the richness that comes from size.
Yale and Oxford are much
smaller more intimate places,
and I came to have an
appreciation for that intimacy
of the undergraduate
experience at those places,
which when I moved back to Madison
I actually tried to set up a
residential college at Madison
based on the Yale and Oxford models
was fascinating attempt to do that.
- You actually have a paper
in which you sort of define
what values you would like to see in
liberal arts students who
really have such an education.
- Yeah, it's an essay called Only Connect
that was published first
in the American Scholar
you can see it on my website.
I actually wrote it at the
time that I was working on
this residential college at Madison,
and in it I tried to
articulate what I defined
as 10 qualities of a
liberally educated mind
that I think of as the
goal of liberal education,
and that I would say research
universities in particular
are often at risk to forget
the kind of very basic things
like learning to read, learning to talk,
learning to put yourself
in another persons frame of reference,
and trying to understand the world
from another point of view.
Those are the civil benefits I would say
of higher education in the
liberal arts tradition.
Then the research
universities which I cherish
I am utterly a creature
of research universities
in terms of my upbringing
and how I think of the world,
but in the research universities
we tend to narrow our focus we dive deep,
and what we get from those
deep dives is extraordinary,
but in the world you
need to also be able to
open the frame back up,
and see those deep dives
in a larger context,
and that to me has been the
great gift of liberal education
to the United States of America.
It's one of the things
I'm really committed to try to preserve
that liberal education
tradition in the United States
at a time when I think it's under threat.
- What is involved what is
the struggle like to implement
this kind of vision at a
major research university?
I mean, what is most frustrating,
and what is most fulfilling?
- Well, again, we could talk
a long time about that one,
but I would say that if I had to give you
two very quick answers to that one,
one would be we specialists,
and I'm as much a specialist as anybody
love nothing more than to
invite you into my specialty,
and show you what a wondrous world
is in this very small place
that I've devoted my
life to understanding.
We're often not so good at saying,
well, see here's this speciality,
and here's this speciality
and here's this specialty
what do they share?
If we were to have a dialogue
across the boundaries
what might that look like?
Although we sometimes
pay lip service to that,
and we certainly say it's important to do
I'm not sure we're actually
all that good always to do it,
and we often throw the kids the undergrads
sort of out into this vast
menu of all these specialties
we want them exposed to,
and we kind of expect
them to do the integrating
rather than us help them do that.
I think the R1s the research universities
are in general not as good at that
as the little liberal arts colleges.
They in many ways I think have
been the keepers of the flame
of that kind of undergrad integration
more than the research
universities have been.
The other thing I would say
as an answer to that question
is I think the big places,
the big research universities
often disempower undergrads
without noticing that they're doing it.
They often take it as an assumption
that the center of the enterprise
are the research faculty,
and maybe their graduate students,
and maybe the research staff,
and the undergraduate mission is not quite
sort of the deep, deep
purpose of the institution
which is not to say
you can't get an absolutely
great undergraduate education
at a Berkeley, or a Madison,
at Ann Arbor, or whatever,
but you have to know how to find it,
whereas, a little liberal arts place
I'm visiting Reed College later this week,
those kind of places that's what they do
the kids are the heart
of their enterprise.
- In a way as an outsider
one sees history as
the best hope in a way,
or one of the best hope
with the humanities
more broadly preserving this
liberal arts perspective,
so let's switch gears here a minute,
and talk about what the
skills and temperament
you see of students
who want to do history,
and who become historians,
and then we'll talk about
how the world is changing.
- Yeah, sure, well, I'm glad you say that
that history is one of the
best hopes of preserving
this liberal arts tradition
because I believe that.
I believe in the others too.
I believe in philosophy,
I believe in literature, all of them,
but I would say history,
and notice all specialists
do what I'm about to do,
so a chemist can say this too.
A geologist can say this too.
There's a way in which
history is the whole world.
There is nothing in the world
that you can't ask a
historical question about,
and the thing you're asking about
becomes bigger and deeper and richer
by having said where did it
come from, why is it this way?
I would say that one of the
habits of mind of the historian
is looking at everything
in the way I just said.
No matter what it is whether
it's the glasses I'm wearing
where did these come?
Who started making them?
Why are they made the way?
How do people grind lenses like this?
When did they start doing that?
We can take anything and do it that way,
but the second question,
the second question that
historians always ask,
and it seems so stupidly
obvious that it's almost trite,
but when you live inside
the second question
it goes forever is what are the documents?
How would I find out where
these glasses came from?
What are all the glasses
that have survived?
When did the first lens maker
write an account of how you grind a lens?
How would I find that
document where would it be?
That looking for looking for documents,
piecing together the
kaleidoscopic jigsaw puzzle
which are all these fragments
which have come down to us from the past
is really not the way other
disciplines ask questions,
so that's one thing that
history gives the world.
The last one I would give you though is
historians are committed
to ordinary language.
They speak plain English
not that they don't use
certain words in special ways,
but they're not as fond
of inventing neologisms,
new words as many disciplines are.
They don't speak a secret language
that only experts know how to understand,
so there's a kind of accessibility
of historical writing
which if you believe
that academic work should be in the world,
and should be accessible to ordinary folks
that ordinary languageness
of history is a good thing,
and one reason for the ordinary
languageness is storytelling
that the commitment to narrative,
the commitment to when
I answer the question
how did it get to be this way?
That invites a story that's
almost a required story
is the answer to that kind of question.
Most disciplines, although, I would argue
they all actually build
narrative, they build story.
They don't actually tell a story.
The rhetoric they use is
not a storytelling rhetoric,
and there is something
about story, I believe,
that is about as deeply a
part of human consciousness
as any feature of the way
human beings make meaning in the world.
We make meaning by telling stories,
and many of the stories
we tell are about the past
that's what history is.
- You were the president
of the American Historical Association,
and in your address and columns
you wrote for that office
you talk about a second component
which is coming to
understand a foreign country,
so in addition to wanting
to know how we got here
you really want to answer that question
by knowing what it was like back then,
but in the terms of the people
who lived in that period.
- Yeah, and this one is a
hard and complicated one
because in general I would
say more often than not
people who are not historians
come to history through the first question
how did things get to be this way?
Certainly, when I teach an 18-year-old
they haven't lived that much history.
They don't have that much
time depth in their own life,
and they have a kind of late adolescence,
and how did I get to be me?
So there's a way in which
one of the most interesting
stories is always,
well, how did I get to be
me and by me I mean us.
So where did we come from
is kind of intrinsically
a starting point for
storytelling about the past,
but for professional historians
we're always a little
nervous about that question
because it kind of implies
that that past back there
existed to become us its
purpose was to become us,
and that could not be
farther from the truth
because those people back
there existed to be them.
They didn't know they
were gonna become us.
Many of them didn't want to become us.
So learning to recognize that
they are equally powerful questions.
In fact, the first one
how do we get to be us
is actually more interesting
when you recognize
how different those
people were back there.
The way I often put this is
the past is a foreign country.
Those people back there
were really unlike us
even those who are nearest to us.
My grandparents my great-parents
people kind of deeply
in my racial gendered classed identities
they are really different from me.
So learning that no matter who they were,
their alienness, their
difference, their autonomy,
the rich selves that they inhabited
I owe them honor, I owe them respect,
and asking how that
complicated world back there
made these really tricky,
unexpected journeys to become our world,
well, those two together become one story,
but not everybody begins
with the second one.
You have to lead them to the second one.
That's what professional historians do.
- So as you go back and
you find this foreign land,
so to speak,
and at the same time
your goal is to figure out
how we got here today
because of that foreign land,
so the historian has to
balance these two things.
Are you saying that storytelling
is a way to carry this
information from the past,
and bring it to the present so
that both fellow historians,
students and a wider audience
will then appreciate this vocation?
- Yes, that's deeply what I believe,
and I think it's deeply
what my discipline believes.
That's the reason why
we really are unapologetic
about narrative.
Many, many disciplines in the 20th century
came to regard narrative as unscientific
because it's not sufficiently ambitious
in the generalizations
that it had to offer,
whereas, there's a way in
which history by its nature
we believe that it's all
of their broad patterns
each story is unique,
and that's the property of storytelling
that if I tell a story
well it's a unique story.
You come to care about the characters,
and the experiences
and the lived realities
of that set of characters
that are in that story.
I do believe, again,
that a deep part of human
pattern making, meaning making
is we empathize with people.
We come to put ourselves in their shoes.
When we can inhabit a
story where we can imagine
being in that place in that time
nothing does that so well
as narrative I would say.
- You have an article which
is on your website about,
I think the article was done
for the Wisconsin Historical Society,
and it's about a particular place that
became preserved,
and was
a historical site,
and you relate that to a
woman who lived in the past.
I think her name was Juliette Kinzie
who actually wrote a book
that described the people and the places,
and why this house which she lived in
was important in terms of those stories,
so this is a particular example
of what you're talking about
that nobody really might
care about this historic site
unless we had her stories.
- Right, exactly right,
and she wrote a book called Wau-Bun,
which I think is one of
the best accounts we have
of life on the Wisconsin
frontier in the 1830s.
Actually, it's in a place
called Portage, Wisconsin
which is a remarkable place.
I've spent literally the last 20 years
working on a huge book
about Portage, Wisconsin.
It was Frederick Jackson
Turner's hometown.
It's where John Muir migrated
as an 11-year-old boy from Scotland.
It's where Aldo Leopold's
Shack was located.
It's the naval of the universe
for American ideas of nature,
but there's also Juliette Kinzie
sitting in what was called
the Indian Agency House in the 1830s,
and she wrote this book.
It's not a particularly
dramatic or ambitious book.
It's about life on the frontier,
but she's a wonderful writer.
She's a storyteller she
is herself telling stories
about the world she's in,
and because she's such a vivid storyteller
she sees so vividly and she
builds stories so vividly
she's actually one of our best windows
onto that world back then,
so she becomes a character in my story,
and that's, in fact, I think
how history and storytelling work.
There's stories that become
objects of other stories,
and those stories become
objects of stories.
It's this ever elaborating
web of narrative,
which is what we swim
in with human beings.
- There's a challenge here and a dilemma.
The challenge it seems to me is
becoming a historian
requires learning rigor,
learning how to pose a question,
learning how to interview
all sorts of things as one,
and actually you explore
this on your website
which I highly recommend,
but on the other hand it involves
a kind of empathy,
the ability to write and
tell stories and so on
to actually bring out the
humanness of what you discover.
Is this a dilemma or do the two,
the rigor and the historian
which might lead to
boring text and long books
that people might not
read on the one hand,
whereas, the ideal,
you pose the ideal in
your historical address
as being people like
Michael Pollan a journalist,
and John Sayles the movie director
as examples of good storytelling.
Is there a conflict there or not?
- Well, I don't hold them up as the ideal.
I'm a great fan of both of them.
I hold them up as an ideal,
and I contrast their ideal to some extent
with what historians are permitted to do.
It is absolutely true that John Sayles
can invent narratives about the past
that I believe convey
truths about the past.
They're not lies, they're
not just, just fictions
as if that just could
do justice to fiction.
They're full of valuable
insight and meaning,
but they don't follow the
historians rules of evidence
that you're using you're
labeling with the word rigor.
It is true that when I write history
I have to follow the rules of evidence
of my discipline or my colleagues,
and my discipline
generally won't recognize
that I've made a legitimate
claim about the past.
Now I think you can do
that in very engaging ways.
In fact, even when I'm arguing
I usually narrate argument.
I usually will tell you a
story about an argument,
and I'll build that argument
as if it had a kind of
narrative shape to it,
a narrative flow I can tell you a story
that will step you through
the stages of an argument,
but in my discipline I have
to show you my evidence.
I have to show you what
the basis is back then
some fragment that has
survived from back then
that permits me to make
the claim that I'm making.
My colleagues in this
discipline are very nervous
about certain kinds of leaps.
Empathy is one of the
territories where we get nervous
because if I make
an unearned leap,
and I imagine that I can put
myself inside the head of
Juliette Kinzie at the
Indian Agency House,
and pretend that I'm her
very likely I will violate her reality.
Very likely I will sort of say,
well, of course, she's like
me she's got the same fears.
She's got the same beliefs,
and unless I've worked very
hard to bound that claim,
and say, you know,
people back in the 1830s
did not have that set of beliefs.
They did not expect their
lives to look that way,
and if you take your
21st century assumptions,
and map them under her you're
actually describing yourself
you're not describing her,
so we work very hard to
test those empathic move.
I don't think that let's us
off the empathetic hook though
because ultimately once
you've done all that work,
once you've tried to
understand her reality
you still have to say
now that I have this
much richer understanding
of what it would have been
like to be Juliette Kinzie
living on the Wisconsin frontier,
this educated New England
woman that finds herself
from her point of view out
in the middle of nowhere
what would that have been like?
Well, then I can start
imagining within the bounds,
within the limits of my evidence,
and I think I can still make you
care about her by doing that,
but it's a tricky business.
- How do you learn storytelling?
Do you learn from alternative
ways of doing storytelling
as you did in your presidential
address always pulling back
as you just described because
you're not doing fiction
in the way John Sayles is for example?
- Yeah, no, I would say that.
I think the way I learned storytelling,
and the way I try to teach my students
to learn storytelling is to
recognize that it's all story,
everything story is
around you all the time.
When you watch Steven Spielberg tell you
Abraham Lincoln's story,
when you read David Donald's
biography of Lincoln,
or when you read Lincoln's
own speeches and letters
they're all different takes on
this complicated human being
that you're trying to understand
and they're all fair game
so that's one way of
looking at Abraham Lincoln.
That's one way of
understanding his reality.
I would say the more
different ways of that
you pay attention to.
One of the things I tell my
students over and over again
is that if you want to be a writer,
if you want to be a historian,
if you want to be a storyteller
you need to read not just
for content but for form,
and you need to read as a storyteller,
you need to read as a writer.
Another thing I tell them
as part of that is that
when you're riveted by the story you're
turning the pages like
crazy pause, and say why?
What's this writer doing
that's doing this to me?
Conversely when you're
bored out of your mind
when you've turned the last five pages,
and realize you have no
memory of them at all
you've read the same paragraph five times,
and you just can't stay focused on it
that's actually kind of interesting.
It's actually not boring
to ask why is this boring?
So when you read as a writer even boredom,
even a boring text can be
an exercise in figuring out
how does a writer lose track
of their audience so much
that they bore that audience,
and the audience stops reading.
There's no more disastrous
thing for a writer to do
then for the reader to go
I'm not coming back to that.
I tell my students to
put a three by five card
over their writing space
that says will the reader turn the page?
Will the reader turn the page?
It's the scariest question
any writer can ask.
- So a student of history
should not look at
Steven Spielberg's movie and say,
well, there are these historical
inaccuracies in the thing,
I mean, you do that.
- [William] You should do that.
- You should do that,
but on the other hand you would
not then dismiss the work,
but see it as a way,
well, how did he make Lincoln interesting?
- Right, that's one thing,
and how did he get us to
empathize with Lincoln?
Why did he choose in the middle
of the Obama administration
to tell that particular
version of Lincoln's story?
How did he create a moral
fable that is as much about
the politics of the early 21st century
as it is a story about the Civil War?
Notice one of the things historians do is
we put everything in history,
so there is a history of
different representations
of Abraham Lincoln.
In that story there's
nothing inaccurate about
Steven Spielberg's Lincoln
because that's a story not about Lincoln
it's a story about stories about Lincoln,
and these days that story,
Spielberg's story, Tony Kushner's story
based on Doris Kearns Goodwin's story,
notice the layers of story
that are happening there.
Each of those is an absolutely authentic
totally accurate depiction
of what one group of artists
in the early 21st century
had to say about Abraham Lincoln.
We can do that with anything.
What I just did you can do with anything.
Again, I joke to my students that
even documents that lie
that are total forgeries
are totally accurate documents
for the history of forgery,
and for the history of lying,
so if you're writing a
history of counterfeiting,
counterfeit documents are
actually totally accurate,
100% accurate and indispensable
for the history of counterfeiting.
- You identify in your
work during your presidency
at the American Historical Association
two really formidable challenges.
One is the students,
and the extent to which
their prior education
when you get them in the classroom
may not have prepared them
to read, to think, to write
all of the values that
you see so important
for a liberal education,
so on the one hand there's the challenge
of the student body and
what we do about that.
On the other hand is the
challenge of the digital age,
and both are leading
us away from critical thinking,
from rigor, from reading long-form books.
Talk a little about that,
and how we address those two
challenges which are related
because the technology is
supporting the students
in their ability to not
have the standards of rigor,
and of being able to read,
of distinguishing between
a book and a website.
- Well, that's a really deep question,
and there were a number of
elements to that question
that I would want to
tease apart a little bit.
- [Harry] Please do.
- One thing I would say is that
if we take the classic 18
to 22-year-old undergraduate
which, of course, is
no longer is normative
in some ways as it once was as a category
they have always come to college
with a whole series of
misconceptions and limitations,
and the whole purpose
of college I would say,
and this I hope will never change
is our job as teachers is
to meet them where they are.
It does no good to complain about,
well, in the wonderful
glory years of the past
students had all these
skills they don't have,
and that isn't what you just said,
but there is a tendency
for middle-aged people
to look back on the glory
days of their youth,
and kids today aren't like that.
I have no patience for that.
These kids bring a wealth of experiences.
They bring digital
competences, visual competences
that my generation for the
most part totally lacked,
so it's not that they
don't bring knowledge
they bring lots of knowledge,
but that's where the other
part of your question,
I think, kicks in which is
they are not used to reading long texts.
I would say actually
most adults are no longer
all that used to reading long texts.
We are now all of us spending
more and more of our time
in chopped up bloggy, tweety, Facebooky
very short units of information,
which by their nature of
radically decontextualized.
The experience of the search
engine the Google experience
is that when we need information
our dominant metaphor now is
I grab the information,
and I grab it and it's this big,
and in grabbing it the
way I just grabbed it
I ripped it out of the
context that it was in,
and I didn't actually
have to work very hard
to extract it from that context.
One of the things
historians believe strongly
is that that struggle to find
this piece of information,
and it's buried in this tangle,
and as we work our way into
the tangle to figure it out
we learn not just the piece of information
we learn the tangle,
and it's the tangle that
educates our intuition,
and gives us this kind of
rich intuitive knowledge
about what that world was like.
I would say kids today
like most of us today
are more impatient we want things quickly.
I regularly this astonishes
me this never used to happen
I now regularly get emails.
That's the other thing we
think we can just email people
for information rather
than find it ourselves.
I get emails from
undergraduates and I kid you not
I get more than one or
two of these a month,
and the kid says literally
my professor has assigned me
to write a book report about your book
can you tell me what it's about?
The kid is not trying to cheat.
They don't think that they're
doing something wrong.
I don't want to be snarky
I'm a teacher to them too.
My job is to meet them where they are,
and this is a student who thought
that the way you write a book
report is contact the author,
and ask the author what the book is about.
Never in a million years
would that have occurred to me
as an undergraduate,
but, of course, it's so easy now,
so I have to very gently
and as kindly as I can say,
you know, the answer to
your question is in my book.
You might want to read it.
It's changing that way of
thinking that idea that
you don't have a primary
experience of reality.
You have a virtual experience of reality,
and a Wikipedia summary is all you need
as a way of accessing that reality.
There's some complicated changes going on.
- Historians in a way
are positioned to adapt to the web
even though they may resist the web.
I draw this conclusion from
your emphasis on storytelling,
and also what you've
written about your teachers,
and the way they might use
pictures or multimedia.
In the classroom they
are having to articulate
their research in ways that
students can understand
and will be enthralled by
so in a way teaching and storytelling
are a stepping stone to
move into the digital age
historians just have to think about it.
- I think that's right.
It's a vice virtue thing.
One of our virtues is that
we do think in stories.
Stories are accessible we
write in ordinary language.
Another advantage is that
almost alone, not quite alone,
but almost alone among
the academic disciplines
we're still a book discipline.
The vast majority of academic disciplines
now have their principle
intellectual output
in academic journals
which notice have the
interesting attribute
that they don't need to
assemble their audiences.
The audience is already preassembled.
The group of specialists is
gathered around that journal,
and the goal is the most
efficient communication
of new findings to that expert audience,
so there's not a problem of translation.
You've already got the experts,
and you want to get it to
them as quickly as possible.
They don't want to be
bored with explication
because they already know
the context, whereas,
when you write a book you
have no guaranteed audience.
Every book has to build its own audience.
It has to create its own audience,
so the narrative act
of imagining the other
to whom you're communicating,
and the commitment of my discipline
to ordinary language when I write a book
I do not just want my
colleagues to read it.
I want anybody who is
interested to feel intrigued by
the invitation I'm giving them
to come into this really cool space
that I want to share with
them that's the virtue.
To finish, though, with
the vice we like books.
The default of my discipline
we're never so happy
as when we can write
a 250 to 500 page book
to tell you a long, long story
about what happened back then,
and that is not the way
most people now read.
Long, long reading,
particularly, long complicated,
technical demanding reading
is less and less common
as an active pleasure.
So I would say that the biggest
deficit as I experience it
that my undergraduates now
bring into the classroom
is they most of them, many of them,
no longer read long books for pleasure.
It's not part of their lived reality
that you would pick up.
We always name Harry Potter,
but I think Harry Potter
is the exception to prove the rule,
and Rowling is a genius
at the narrative momentum
that she can use to suck people up,
and carry them for 800 pages.
That's not the way most books work.
Persuading kids that reading long
is still a valuable
thing to do is hard work,
and here now I'll finally
answer your question this way.
One of the things I believe,
and I don't think this comes
naturally to my discipline,
but it does come naturally to storytelling
is that there's a way in which any story
can be told at any length.
I can tell you Anna Karenina in 800 pages.
I can summarize it for you in 100 pages.
I can summarize it in a paragraph.
I can, in fact, tweet it,
and I can capture a
reality about that book.
Now if I tweet it
you're losing an awful lot
of Tolstoy when I do that,
but remembering that all
narrative is scalable.
It loses richness and
subtlety and complexity
as you scale it down,
but I do think that that's
the lesson of the digital age.
We need to learn how
to tell our narratives
construct our arguments,
put things in the public
realm on multi scales,
and my anxiety one of my missions
in the time I have left to me
is to try to keep defending the long-form.
The full length Anna Karenina say
is just a fictional
metaphor for long narrative.
At the same time
that I'm trying to help
me and my colleagues
get our work out into the blogosphere,
get it out into Facebook,
get it out into much smaller
units of argumentation,
or for that matter in multimedia
on television and video
the space that we're in right now.
YouTube has opened up
this kind of conversation
what was never possible before.
When you began these interviews
they were nowhere near
as accessible to the
world as they are now,
and that's a wondrous thing.
It's an amazing thing that you
and I can talk for an hour,
and there will be people
all around the world
that can access it
that's something that never
before could have been done,
and we need to lean into that
the way you've been leaning into it.
- Thank you.
Let's talk a little about
environmental history
because you are a leading
figure in environmental history
what does history
bring to our understanding
of the environment?
At one point I think I
read where you said that
one's goal as an environmental historian
is to bring nature into history basically.
Talk a little about that.
- Environmental history is
the history of human beings
interactions with the
natural world over time.
It's the history of
environmental politics.
It's the history of our
changing ideas of nature,
and one of the interesting things about
our ideas of nature taking
the United States as the frame
as I typically do I'm a U.S. historian.
I work largely in the
geography of the United States.
Nature in the United States has often been
a kind of romantic early
19th century nature which is
static and stable, beautiful,
equilibrated whole,
and there is a story that Americans
have often told themselves,
and that I would say environmentalists
still tell themselves
in which the human past is a story
of our taking that stable
nature and transforming it,
and a story that was very
important to American history
was the story of progress
in which we take a savage wilderness,
raw nature and convert
it into civilization,
converted in progress.
That's Frederick Jackson Turner's story
of the American frontier which
has all sorts of erasures.
Native people have a very awkward place
in that particular narrative.
There's an environmental
story which as often as not
says that nature was good and whole
before we got our hands on it
and boy have we trashed it,
and the story is a story
of a fall from that nature.
Both of those are human ideas.
Both of those stories say as much about us
as they do about nature,
so what environmental history seeks to do
is to call our attention to
a world out there of nonhuman
beings and processes,
landscapes, environments that
we could not exist without.
Our life utterly, utterly depend
on all those relationships,
and yet much of the time we pay
no attention to them at all,
or we put ourselves at
the center of the story,
and ignore all those beings
with whom we share this planet.
I think the great achievement
of environmental history
has been to say you can't write history
without at least paying
attention to pick something,
dandelions, smallpox,
the wheat plant and think about the story
of our relationship to those things
because it's a really interesting,
really complicated story.
- Does environmental history
have important lessons
for the environmental movement?
- I believe so.
I've been working for a
while now on a book called
Saving Nature In Time
and the title is a pun.
It basically makes the argument that
those mythic stories that we
do like to tell ourselves,
and that have great power,
and that I like to tell myself too about
wondrously whole nature that
if only we could get back to it
the world would be good again.
Well, that's not actually the way
even nature without us looked like.
That nature without us has a history too.
Geology tells that story,
evolutionary biology tells that story,
asteroids have hit this planet,
and species have gone extinct.
There's some big dramatic stories
that are part of that nonhuman past.
I would say one of the lessons
for environmental politics
is that when you start
telling yourself a story
that begins in a place of stasis,
and moves to a place of dynamism
that looks bad or crisis
you should step back and ask yourself
whether that story is too easy.
One of the criticisms and I'm
a lifelong environmentalist
I do this work because I believe in
building a sustainable human relationship
to this world that we share
with all those beings
that I named earlier.
One of the things I
believe very, very strongly
is that it's very easy to
tell very dramatic stories
about how human beings
have affected the planet
that lead to despair and lead
us to say we're just awful.
The world would be a much better place
if humanity would go extinct tomorrow.
Although I get that emotion,
I have felt that emotion.
Many, many people that care about nature
have felt that emotion
it's actually not a very useful emotion.
I sure would not want to
build a political movement,
or a cultural movement a
moral movement on despair,
so I'm actually a great
believer in complicated stories
that have fearful things in them,
but that also have some kind
of vision of hope in them.
That's not a historical
project that's a moral project.
It's a political project.
If you ask what does environmental
history have to offer
environmentalism or to Americans
who may not call themselves
environmentalists,
but they want to give a
sustainable relationship
to the world, to their
children and grandchildren
then I think we need to
tell complicated stories
that don't just lead to despair.
The Pollyanna sentimental
stories that say,
oh, do whatever you want it's all great
those are dangerous stories too.
We need something in between.
- So the interaction
between nature and humanity
that story involves interactions
that aren't gonna go away,
but by understanding this complex story
then you inform choices
about the environment.
- Right, one of the
lessons history teaches
very deeply, very deeply it's like one of
the core faiths of my discipline
is that we look at the
world as it is today,
and before we ask a
historical question about it
it looks given, it looks natural,
this is just the way the world is.
As soon as you ask the question,
well, how did the world
get to be this way,
suddenly it's no longer a given thing.
It's something that became this thing,
and as you go back as you start looking
what you start to realize
going to your question
is people made choices.
The world as we now experience it
is a product of human choice,
and actually choices
by other organisms too
in a funny kind of way.
The more you learn that
the more you recognize,
well, you know, we're making choices too.
What choices should we be
making as we imagine the future
because we're writing history now too.
People are gonna be writing
about us 100 years from now.
What stories do we imagine
them telling about us,
and what stories would we
like them to tell about us?
That leads to really
interesting politics I think.
- One final question as
somebody who is committed
to understanding the past,
and conveying that knowledge, information,
and values to the present,
but at the same time you're very sensitive
to how the world is changing,
how nature is changing,
so how would you advise students
to prepare for the future?
- Get liberally educated.
I go back to it's an
old-fashioned piece of advice,
but one of the things I
deeply, deeply believe
is the more you know about the world,
and I'm speaking passionately
about the historian's frame here,
but I'm nearly as passionate
about the geologist's frame,
the chemist's frame, the
literary critic's frame.
Those are all really,
really not just valuable,
and necessary frames
they're really cool frames.
They're really interesting.
So one thing I would say to a student is
don't work on boredom don't be bored.
If you're bored by something
figure out why you're bored,
and figure out how not to be bored.
If a liberal education well
lived does anything at all
it teaches us how not to
move through the world as a boring place.
I think when people aren't bored,
and are generous in their curiosity,
in their willingness to learn
about another human being,
or another way of being in the world
I think that leads to good places,
so don't be bored would
be one of the things
I'd offer as a lesson.
- Well, on that note Professor Cronon
I want to thank you for taking the time
for this absolutely
fascinating discussion.
- Thanks for having me it was a pleasure.
- Thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.